davos
carroll machen daraus hostelworld und
damit vor
[Musik]
jedes jahr im januar ist in davos der
bär los
die spitzen aus politik und wirtschaft
feiern das hochamt der globalisierung
und weil geld bekanntlich nicht stinkt
schreiben sich die reichen und mächtigen
ein wohn riechendes motto auf die fahne
eine gemeinsame zukunft in einer
zersplitterten welt
hallo
während er alle aufmerksamkeit auf sich
zieht erkunden wir davos diese
zersplitterte welt
[Musik]
natürlich denn ich sage jetzt mal hinter
vorgehaltener hand schießt jeder
bezahlen stau steht
aber jeder denkt den schritt weiter und
sei ohne dass das bringt er so viel
wirtschaftskraft in den kantonen und das
vor allem in der stadt wien und graz ist
eine marke der 2008er der deutsche
milchtechnologe die die nietzsche lebt
seit acht jahren in davos
er weiß aus erfahrung nach vier tagen
ist der spuk vorbei
[Musik]
die molkerei davos verarbeitet für ihren
bündner hobel these ausschließlich
rohmilch aus diesen tank
die milch ist von höchster qualität weil
die kühe im winter ausschließlich mit
heu gefüttert werden keine fleisch ist
der einzige bauer in der region der auf
billiges silofutter verzichtet großer
aufwand kleiner gewinn business
management würde ob diesem idealismus
wohl den kopf schütteln
[Applaus]
estland als 17
und walter sind ja
überschwänglich schneider stellenwechsel
da liegen die positionen von bauer
fleisch und präsident jump vielleicht
gar nicht so weit auseinander
ein schritt in eine gemeinsame zukunft
in der zersplitterten welt
[Musik]
viele bild lebt erst seit vier monaten
wieder in davos
15 jahre lang bewirtschaftete er in
chile ein stück land das sein vater
einst gekauft hatte bis die ureinwohner
auf seinen hof kamen und sein land für
sich beanspruchten
sehr sämtliche stau
mit rost ins rosa trikot
sämtliche maschinen
landwirtschaftsmaschinen monika alles
zweijährige sohn habe intern immer
wieder frieden haben
diesen dreier
philipp wild wurde opfer der
zersplitterten welt über deren
gemeinsame zukunft hier in davos
debattiert wird
und weil die debattiere in ihren
schwarzen limousinen tagsüber die
straßen verstopfen muss er in der nacht
arbeiten selbst ein entwurzelter der
39-jährige genau was sein thema wäre am
rednerpult des wef
mit
ja es ist unser flüchtlinge ist schon
muss nicht schon haben aber
das problem ist
im landhaus la red leben jene die von
den problemen im eigenen land bereits
vertrieben wurden asylsuchende
gestrandet im ehemaligen
feinschmeckerlokal am rand von davos
lehre christoph eberhard unterrichtet
die oberstufenschüler auch hier macht
sich das bemerkbar da festplatten
rechten fahren mit dem bus so lange ich
rief also viel will ich dort gesehen
niemand kontrollieren und sagt das ist
einfach aber für mich kein problem
86 menschen aus der ganzen welt wohnen
gelebte globalisierung gewissermaßen die
meisten sind omas unbegleitete
minderjährige asylsuchende vor dem wef
hat die polizei 42 mal eine razzia
durchgeführt
40 mann durchkämmten das gebäude
helikopter uniformierte waffen bei
flüchtlingen aus krisenregionen weckt
das erinnerungen
gerade bei den kleinsten hat
zentrumsleiterin michelle stephanie
beobachtet dass die kinder und das ist
natürlich nicht sehr positiv sehe und
dass viele milliarden sie einfacher und
füreinander land kommen und und wirklich
krieg erlebt hat ann marie stammt aus
dem kongo einem jener länder dass der
amerikanische präsident unterschied all
countries ab sie lebt seit sechs jahren
hier und weiß was sie dem amerikanischen
präsidenten sagen würde würden sie zu
möchte präsident
es ist ein glück dass ich sie treffe ich
möchte sie bitten helfen sie in meinem
land
ich spreche jetzt nur für mein land ich
bin nicht in europa weil ich einfach
lust dazu hatte
ich bin geflohen wegen der probleme in
einem land hier in der schweiz ist die
polizei führt die leute da bei uns ist
das anders da hilft einem niemand vor
allem nicht wenn man kein geld hat
deshalb musste ich fliehen das würde ich
dem präsidenten sagen
lieber als über trump spricht an marie
aber über jemand anderen darf ich noch
etwas über meine direktorin sagen sie
heißt michael steffani ich respektiere
sie sehr sie kümmert sich um uns
ich möchte allen sozialarbeitern in der
schweiz sagen
kümmert euch um die asylsuchenden wie
michele stephanie das macht sie hält ihr
wort
ich bewundere sie die frauen kennen sich
gut aus jahrelanger erfahrung wissen
beide und die scherben der
zersplitterten welt in der der kleine
elli aufwachsen wird
[Applaus]
[Musik]
der präsident nicht dicht hier
der journalist der die sondersendung
anlässlich seiner rede moderiert etwas
bescheidener
was soll's der vielgepriesene geist von
davos überstrahlt alles irgendwie stören
oder sogar dass das gericht für
reichlich also das waren eigentlich
einmal - 421 glaubt hat ein vater seine
frau gern aber es bleibt so wenn
überhaupt aber es ist ein traum für mich
steht das im studio tisch um das rund
ein anderer von der leyen der
lka-präsident die beste akademiker und
eine frage stellen kontrolliert und
sheens ging das dann ganz gut
stephan klapproth nutzt das frühstück
und mit einem seiner gäste die
sondersendung vorzubereiten
martina wie ceo der
schweizerisch-amerikanischen
handelskammer provoziert aufgebrochen
und so straff zeitmaschine und so
martina und die business sitzen ganz
begeistert sie dass er doch ein
da melden sich schon mit den aktiv
sitzen also damit können die
zehnjährigen oder eine gesetzlich so
viel pop und so viele autos braucht
weiterhin gesperrt werden sie können
sich nicht ausgegeben werden sie schauen
was alles über die projektion für die
für den markt und auf meine show klasse
dass der apokalypse als ob die mich
zurück da ist oder wenn sie der trend
wieder treffen
deshalb ist sie nur in frage wenn die
schränke viertelstunde mit dem reden wie
die schufa suchen so stark dass die laut
terrorismus und für andere ist er sehr
wichtig
und das sind die partner von amerikas
multilateralismus extrem wichtig sich zu
der holländer dran handelt anderen
andere und das über multilateralismus
außen platzhalter dass musik einen
genauso wenig wie sie wissen was noch
wäre da wahrscheinlich dass freundlich
selbst durch eine gebrochene kniescheibe
lässt sich stephan klapproth nicht
stoppen
aber näher als beim defilee kommt der
der mächtigsten mann der welt nicht
was für das land ist das ist friedlich
nicht die zersplitterung der welt der
bruch der milch von bauer preis treibt
andrin st luzen in der molkerei davos um
[Musik]
qualität stimmt dass man das nicht
schlecht bewertet es wirklich nachher
heiß lief noch zwei jahre lang und dass
man zwei jahre aus dem kreis sucht frau
gelang die fdp ist es sehr wichtig dass
qualität schlimmen trockenheit vom bruch
als bruch beschaffenheit des betrachters
buchhorn ich dann mit aller lager dazu
ein erfahrungswert wenn auch erfolgloser
presse
den lage bruchsicher und nicht und wir
sehen überhaupt keine witze geworden
von käse versteht der milchtechnologe
mehr als von weltpolitik die schaffung
einer besseren zukunft will er den
herren im anzug die gerade nebenan im
kongresszentrum tagen trotzdem nicht
überlassen
ein skifahrer verfahren hier setzt
umwelt kann jeder mensch mache auch in
ganz ganz viele bereiche wo lebt kann
nicht viel machen zum standard
und mit der masse macht's system
brock little kommt aus phoenix arizona
und ist der topskorer des hc davos
der amerikaner muss sich einiges anhören
zeit sein mächtiger landsmann die welt
verblüfft ich habe gehört ihre kollegen
reifen ständig wegen ihnen und tom ja
vor allem mein trainer und ich glaube er
ist kein trumpf in fahrt kam es auch
aber er hat mich aus amerika nennt mich
der traum freistoß
nein nicht wirklich
es ist vielleicht lustig aber ich mag
den übernommen nicht
der linke flügel trainiert mit der
blauen nummer 10
[Applaus]
der mächtigste mann seiner welt ist
trainer arno del cuto
auf dem eis geht es ruppig zu und her
trotzdem hat der sport erreicht dass
zumindest auf der koreanischen halbinsel
die zersplitterte welt etwas
zusammenrückt letzte woche wurde ja
bekannt dass nord und südkorea bei den
olympischen spielen ein gemeinsames
frauen hockey team stellen und unter
einer flagge einlaufen
solche kleinen gesten können eine große
wirkung haben
ich habe das glück für die usa bei den
spielen dabei sein zu dürfen und freue
mich bereits auf die eröffnungszeremonie
organisieren
[Applaus]
sie sehen die live übertragung meine
damen und herren aus davos vom
weltwirtschaftsforum wo sie aber nichts
gesehen und gehört eben donald trump
gesprochen hat martina will aber die
rede sehr gepflegt und er selber hat auf
alles verzichtet auf die showelemente es
nicht reingekommen hat gewunken und hat
das einen üblichen zeigen gemacht der
amerikanische präsident zieht ab seit
für das fazit aus journalisten sicht
strategie hanni erwartet wird dass
message bezug von ihr internationales
america first heißt amerika und ihr
können alle mitmachen dass er mich
erwartet was mich überrascht hat ist die
rhetorische qualitäts sie vor der
rettung der club wo ich da geschrieben
oder dress vor der ministerpräsidenten
tag das ist flach sie rhetorischen damit
ist durch die einzige mehr doppelpunkte
gez fast response sanft und schön könnte
landwirt eine plage arbeitet im winter
auch als taxifahrer
der stolze walzer gehört nicht zu den
vorgarten once den vergessenen der
globalisierten welt
er steht auf der sonnenseite und rund
läuft
es könnte so einfach sein
doch die zersplitterte welt wird auch in
einem jahr noch um eine gemeinsame
zukunft ringen